the late  most high  most mighty  and most excellent monarch  elizabeth ii  by the grace of god  of the united kingdom of great britain  and all northern ireland  and of her other realms and territories  queen  head of the commonwealth  defender of the faith  and sovereign  of the most noble  order of the garter  [Music]  [Applause]  um  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  let us humbly beseech almighty god to  bless  with long life  health and honor  and all worldly happiness  the most high  most mighty and most excellent monarch  our sovereign lord  charles iii  now by the grace of god  of the united kingdom of great britain  and northern ireland and of his other  realms and territories  king  head of the commonwealth  defender of the faith  and sovereign of the most noble order of  the garter